in 2011 zack snyder's stylish violent
soccer punch hit theaters and introduced
audiences to a cost of butt stomping
young ladies in leather with a steampunk
sensibility and complex fantasy inside a
dream narrative and memorable
performances from a cast of up and
comers it was one of the most unique
films of the year even if critics kind
of hated it but what happened to baby
doll and her friends after the camera
stopped rolling is where they all ended
up Emily Brown some folks thought that
sucker punch would catapult Emily
Browning to a-list superstar status but
her career ejector II was still just as
oddball and eclectic as ever
turns out of typical Hollywood
trajectory is the last thing on her mind
she's been very picky about when and
where she shows up on screen since
sucker punch her most mainstream role in
the past five years was in the
historical disaster flick Pompeii but a
Beretta butter is the foreign and
festival circuit where she turns up in
movies that most mainstream audiences
will never even hear about let alone see
in theaters as is 2017 you're most
likely to catch her on the small screen
where she scored a prime role in the
Starz adaptation of Neil Gaiman's
American Gods she's also kept a low
profile in real life dating a guy much
less famous than she is and running an
eclectic Instagram account that it says
on Hollywood as they come Vanessa
Hudgens sucker punch was a big moved
away from Vanessa Hudgens Disney roots
and she kept moving in the same
direction with follow-up roles in spring
breakers and Gimme Shelter
however Hudgens clearly hasn't gotten
the musical theatre geek entirely out of
a system a few years after a gun
slinging grenade throwing Turner's
blondie she was back to belting ballads
as Betty Rizzo on grease live more
recently she's enjoyed a starring role
on primetime TV comedy powerless where
she plays an employee at Wayne security
developing products to keep people safe
during destructive superhero battles she
also keeps up with fans on Instagram
because of course she does abbie cornish
you gotta love a beak Ornish's capacity
for reinvention before sucker punch she
was known primarily as the leading lady
of the period romance
right star but just as Cornish refused
to be pigeonholed into a course headed
career after that she also kept it
interesting and unusual after a
leather-clad turn and sucker punch she's
starring in Geo Storm an action flick
with Gerard Butler working with mega
stars Woody Harrelson and Frances
McDormand on a dark comedy and speaking
out in an eloquent defense of the
controversial film where hands touch and
that's not all
Cornish is also known to occasionally
take a break from acting life to spit
rhymes in his second career as a rapper
yeah really
Jena Malone
by the time she scored a role in sucker
punch Jena Malone had been acting for
ages
she didn't slow down afterward in 2012
she traded a leather bust year for a
long skirt and high neck blouse on the
period TV drama Hatfields and McCoys the
following year she joined the cast of
the Hunger Games Catching Fire is
Johanna Mason Malone reteamed with
sucker punch director Zack Snyder in
2016 the Batman vs Superman dawn of
Justice but her scenes as Janet Clyburn
were deleted from the theatrical release
lately though Malone is less involved in
Hollywood and more interested in her new
roles as a mum a photographer and a
writer
the actress gave birth to her first
child with fiance Ethan della Renzo in
May 2016 and now she shares thoughts
poetry's and photos on a blog called our
mountain family that's a long way from
gunning down bad guys jamie chung
scoring a role in sucker punch was a
major coup for jamie chung who got her
start on MTV's the real world and used
the show as a launch pad into a legit
acting career since 2011 you're most
likely to have seen her in repeat
appearances on once upon a time where
she plays the role of Mulan or hurt her
in the role of go-go in big hero 6 which
she'll be reprising for the TV series
too and Chong hasn't left the action
realm behind she's being cast as the
teleporting mutant blink in Fox's new
x-men series
kalla group g9 of the playing of
therapists /dance madam in soccer punch
collared Gugino hasn't lost the taste
for the dark and weird since then she's
held down major roles in wayward Pines
and Californication and she's even
teamed up with director Zack Snyder for
a third and fourth time lending a voice
to a Kryptonian robot and then
Kryptonian spaceship in his Superman
films as of 2017 she's starring in the
sci-fi spectacle the space between us
and a feature film adaptation of the
Stephen King novel Gerald's game Oscar
Isaac between ex machina x-men
apocalypse and star wars the force
awakens he can't go to the movies these
days without seeing Oscar Isaac in some
form or another which makes him the one
member of Snyder's sucker-punch cast
who's exponentially more famous now than
he was in 2011
Isaac was right at the start of his
career when he scored a minor role in
sucker punch now he's one of the hottest
actors in Hollywood with half of the
Dozen prestigious projects coming down
the pike but perhaps because he's got so
many famous so fast
Isaac keeps a comparatively low profile
in real life he's so secretive about his
private life that is practically an
entire cottage industry dedicated to
unraveling the mysteries of how he
spends his time when he's not on screen
Jon Hamm though he kept busy with Mad
Men for most of the early 2000s Jon Hamm
was never so busy that he couldn't take
a moment between seasons to show up in a
movie or two and in Sucker Punch he
played a small but pivotal role in one
narrative he's the brothel smarmy VIP
client in the other he's The Asylum
doctor who lobotomize his helpless young
ladies with a stainless steel wall
needless to say Jon Hamm didn't
disappear after sucker punch she
continued for another several years on
Mad Men winning a Golden Globe and an
Emmy for his performances Don Draper not
that it's all been sunshine and daisies
for him in the intervening years his
longtime relationship with jennifer
Westfeldt ended in 2015 just a few
months after ham announced that he'd
entered rehab for alcohol addiction but
he still has soared after his ever next
up look for him in Edgar Wright's hotly
anticipated heist flick baby driver
Scotland there's just something about
Scott glint that says grizzled badass
which is why after appearing his baby
dull pseudo spirit guide in sucker-punch
he's since gone on to play virtually the
same role in the Netflix series
daredevil only - his eyesight and plus a
very big stick
Glenny is as top of screen as the
characters he plays the dude is
approaching 80 and still trains with
SEAL Team 6 to stay in shape for his
roles and when he's not making a movie
or TV show he's a die-hard thrill seeker
if he's not on camera you'll probably
find him riding motorcycles jumping out
of planes or spearfishing in the middle
of the open ocean when you're beating up
fish with your bare hands you know
you've made it thanks for watching click
the looper icon subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you love to
[Music]